North Korean dictator Kim jong-un says
he wants to finalize the roadmap to
remove all nuclear weapons from the
Korean Peninsula by the end of President
Trump's first term Kim also praised and
expressed confidence in the president
according to South Korean officials a
delegation from Seoul met with Kim
yesterday in North Korea and delivered a
message from mr. Trump those talks come
ahead of a summit between the leaders of
North and South Korea later this month
in Pyongyang Ben Tracy has just arrived
in the North Korean capital and joins us
live Ben good morning good morning so
negotiations with North Korea to give up
its nuclear weapons have not been going
well but North Korean state media did
say today that Kim jong-un is still
committed to denuclearization now on
Wednesday Kim met with envoys from South
Korea according to the South Koreans he
said that despite difficult negotiations
he still has faith in president Trump
and has never spoken ill of him Kim says
he wants to end his country's hostile
relationship with the US by the end of
the president's first term now at their
summit in Singapore in June President
Trump and Kim jong-un announced a vague
agreement to work towards
denuclearization but so far North Korea
has not even revealed how many nuclear
weapons it has or where they are now
here in Pyongyang this weekend North
Korea is planning to stage a major
military parade to celebrate the 70th
anniversary of the founding of this
country despite once again showing off
his weapons Kim jong-eun says he wants
this peninsula to be a cradle of peace
Nora let's see what steps he plans to
take to do that Ben Tracy in North Korea
thank you